we're here with jacob bertrand and sholo
maraduena from the hit show my favorite
cobra kai
um all right will you guys uh play a
game with us yeah because you guys have
this awesome uh podcast yes and you guys
love to talk about everything and
anything on your podcast and i was
wondering if i could get your take on a
few things trending in the news and pop
culture yeah and we're gonna call it
trends with friends perfect
all all right
okay i'll read a trending topic and you
give me your thoughts are you ready okay
yes okay megan fox and machine gun kelly
recently got matching pedicures would
you get a matching pedicure with your
significant other or a potential date
this is definitely the weird thing
they've done
they uh
yeah of course
like a little inside joke nails i don't
know if i would get like just
french tips
with my girl would do that would feel
odd yeah you got to get them pointy so
that yeah you got to get them nice nice
and sharp little claws there no of
course get your toes right boys come on
you know you don't know
it just tickles it really tickles yeah i
think that's the biggest hurdle for me
speaking of you accidentally punched
each other in the face right yes yeah we
have we have not each other just show up
right yes actually not each other i've
punched him in the face
yeah no no i when you're roommates
anything goes with me all right
chocolate milk was recently listed as
one of the top go-to after workout
snacks you guys trained so hard for this
show does this sound appetizing
i live off of chocolate milk it's his
favorite drink no yeah our fridge of all
time miss drew barrymore you have no
clue our fridge is stocked with
chocolate milk
and
the man is lactose intolerant almond
milk
didn't mean to out you like that but
but no it's okay you gotta try it oh i
would like it i like almond milk and i'm
gonna try it if you have a brand send it
my way
um okay cardi b is thinking about
getting her son's name tattooed on her
face um i demonstrated earlier i did it
on the jaw it was surprisingly did it
look nice attractive yes maybe a little
chisel maybe brought out the chisel
contour yeah
i think maybe would you guys ever do you
have any tattoos
i do i do have i do have a tattoo
yeah
i do i do have a tattoo my mother knows
i have a tattoo i will say i know she's
watching she will be watching this so
she knows i do have a second tattoo
actually which i have not never
announced
and i don't know why i'm announcing this
is this a daytime tv exclusive this is
the daytime
exclusive jacob actually gave me the
tattoo no a stick
it was a stick and poke i can't say what
it is or where it is but i do have a
second one i'm sorry mom i will say it's
brilliant and it's probably one of my
best pieces of work i will say well
thank you for sharing us that we get to
have the mystery and the exciting news
all at the same time all right a new
dating show that will take place in the
grocery store is in the works it will be
called love at first bite
thoughts i think it's good i think
people flirt in the grocery store you
know you're looking for a cliff bar
and you both hit the same one at the
same time like oh my gosh we both love
rock climbing and then you bond and you
get to hang out i think it's great both
like dark chocolate almond milk oh my
gosh oh my gosh
it's meant to be all right no i think so
i think food is such an important part
of relationships you get like if you
guys aren't into the same foods it's so
hard well also i mean this speaks so
much to the hopefulness of singles like
when i'm in a bookstore or like a
grocery store i am like dying that like
maybe around some corner right it might
be a movie moment waiting to happen
right
just spending a little too long in the
produce section just getting a little
too long and romantic comedy
all right last one katy perry recently
revealed that orlando bloom's worst
habit is he leaves the floss all over
the bathroom
would this bother you and what's your
worst habit
yeah orlando what's going on my man well
shella doesn't floss
right exactly right
okay i have been wishing that i could
just be a fly on the wall in your
roommate heaven and i feel like i got to
be
today i love you guys so much thank you
so much
and we love you yeah thank you so much
for having us oh jacob and show love the
new season of cobra kai is available now
on netflix and be sure to check out
their podcast lone lobos with show low
maraduena and jacob bertrand
[Music]